[Music]
look I've got my issues with creepy
faces and slow pacing and Mass Effect
Andromeda but the one thing I think this
game is doing really well our guns and
we loves us some space guns
unfortunately in Mass Effect Andromeda
you can waste precious time and
resources building a bad gun
I regret you Sidewinder lucky for you
we're here to save you time and
heartache by recommending a few of our
favorite weapons remember you came to
this galaxy to explore new life discern
its intent and then shoot the [ __ ] of it
anyway give us the old thumbs up and
subscribe if you want more if your
favorite line from your childhood was
plasma the now dean to sniper rifle is
your thing it can be picked up off the
cat or crafted we suggest crafting it to
add mods and get its heavy carry weight
down it fires a powerful high explosive
projectile that can detonate nearby fire
barrels rip through shields and deal
area damage it's best combined with rank
5 combat fitness which cuts weapon
weight by 25% or mods such as lattice
material that do the same also with a
mag size of only four shops any mod that
ups ammo count is a plus this weapon
also doubles as a close-range boomstick
if an invisible dog beast mistakes your
arm for a chew toy also in the plasma
department we have the dawn shotgun that
can be picked up from cat and fires a
short-range high damage round in
addition to damage a sizable ammo
capacity of 10 shots makes this your
go-to when dealing with oversized
wildlife this weapon fires single slow
projectiles and is not great against
small fast-moving targets but if you
need to get your targets moving a lot
slower bring along the remnant crowd
gauntlet it is the optimal finisher a
successful hit with this piece of
remnant fisticuffs against an unshielded
target will snap freeze them at worse
that target isn't a problem for the next
few seconds at best that target can now
be shattered with your dawn in glorious
fashion
that shot if you want the best of the
Milky Way you may have brown back some
guns from home such as the Scorpion
pistol this gun fires glorious blobs of
sticky death just fire fire fire and
wait for it
don't forget to calculate the time delay
into your movement plans the great thing
about this gun is that the bad guys are
the last to know that they're already
dead yeah I'm talking to you buddy
if the whole death thing doesn't work
out finish targets with a cute little
Croghan kid hammer seriously read the
description it is made for children if
you want a punchy close-quarter
companion for your swords and hammers
definitely check out the piranha shotgun
with a ten round drum and auto fire
capabilities you can give it to enemies
with punch after staggering punch the
stopping power is so strong that most
enemies won't be able to fight back best
of all this human weapon is available at
the crafting station relatively early in
the game just be sure to add some weight
reducing mods to keep your power
cooldown timers low
if your gun goes dry before the bad guy
gets dead follow up with the uniquely
devastating cat-car fallon its attack
animation takes a bit longer than most
but this alien sword packs a punch and
refills a portion of your shields with
each successful strike this allows you
to stay in close deal more damage and
worry a lot less about dying for
something that works at both close and
mid-range reach for the hornet SMG with
the highest potential fire rate of any
gun in the game this baby can squirt out
950 rounds a minute the catch being that
it fires in three round bursts and takes
a fast trigger pole to get the most out
of it to make this mini bullet hose into
a fire breathing hose buy and equip
specialty ammo 29 fire bullets rapidly
striking a target creates a nice little
barbecue the old GameSpot R&D team is
hard at work in Mass Effect Andromeda
and with many more guns to find we want
to know what you're packin on top of
that n7 armor give us your suggestions
of what we should build next in the
comments below and take a look at our
full review of Mass Effect Andromeda if
you're still on the fence thanks for
watching Pathfinder
you